では よろしくお願いします
えっと 前回はあの 不善心という説明でございました
いわゆる まあ悪い心はなんですかということ
人々はこの まあ一般的に悪いことをするという場合は
どんな心でその行動をするんだということで
そこでまあだいたい 世の中の普通の立場から考えると
あれは悪い これは悪いとまあ勝手に決めてますけどね
ある時期で悪いと思うのは
またある時期になったらいいものになっちゃうし
いいものと思うのはまた後で悪いものになってしまっちゃうし
まあ社会的な立場でも何がいいか何が悪いかっていうのは
そんなまあはっきりしないんですね
その時の都合によって
まあこれは悪い これはいいやとかね
まあいわゆる人間の好き勝手といえば好き勝手なんですね
ですから この社会ではしっかりした善悪判断
判断というものは まあそんなにあるわけじゃないんです
で そういうふうなこの社会の立場から道徳を語ると
仏教もなんかいい加減な宗教になってしまうんですね
時代変わるたびに道徳とか何とかとか全部変えなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
で キリスト教と同じ運命になってしまっちゃうんですね
最初からまあこれでこれはいけません
これはいけませんと決めて
決めつけておけば それ代わりに仏教でいうのは
まあ心の立場から 心は汚れる心がありまして
その汚れて汚れて汚れている心で行動するならば
その行動は不善な行為であると
そうするともう時間とは関係ないんですね
社会とは関係ないんです
やってる行動にも関係ないんです
我々は何をやってるか
何を喋ってるか 何を考えてるかっていう
そのものはあまり関係なく
その考えたり喋ったり行動したりする心が汚れているかないかと
もし汚れているならば
やっていることに関係なく行動は不善になるんですね
で わかりやすく言えば
例えば人の えーと 人生をね
まあダメにしようと思って人にものすごく親切にしてあげることもできるんですね
例えば まあ普通の人はちゃんと勉強して
ちゃんと仕事をして 自分で頑張って生活しなくちゃいけない
で じゃあこの人の人生は無茶苦茶にしようと思って
小さい時からもういろんなものをあげたりとか
まあ勉強しなくたってもいいやと
いくらでもお金ありますから
あげますよと いて そういうふうにまあ大人になるまで
もう何でもあげると 言ったら
ずっとあげるわけにはいきませんだから
まあいつかどこかで止まっちゃうでしょうね
そうすると その人は自分では全然生きていられなくなっちゃうんですね
一人では それで あの やった人は
私はあの人を助けてあげたんだからいいことをしたんだというふうに自慢することは不可能なんです
でも 社会的な立場で見れば
ずっと面倒を見てあげたんだから素晴らしい人だと言うかもしれません
でも 本人の心の中にあったのは
まあこの人のもう面倒を片っ端から見てあげて
その人の が 自立することは
独立することは まあなんとかもうやめようと
あるいは私のものにしようとかね
そういう欲的な希望でやったならば
行為はいくら美しく見えたっても
あまり美しい行動にはならないんですね
ですから そういうふうな感じで
このいろんな社会福祉とかいろいろ見えるんですね
自慢するために 高慢するために
自分たちが偉いというために
まあ人を助けたり いろんなことをやったりはする
点数稼ぎみたいな感じでね
そういうのは まあそれなりの純粋たる不善なる行為だとは言えませんし
そこで仏教は まあそういうふうな問題を解決するためにというよりは
真実を語っているんだから
心が汚れているならば
その汚れている心でやっている行動は全部不善たる行動ですよというふうに決められるようになってるんですね
心は汚れているというと
やっぱりまずむさぼりですか
漏婆ですか まあむさぼりの気持ちで
その心が生まれるという八種類
八種類がありまして で
それはまあ汚れている心で
それから怒りの心は二つありまして
その怒りの心でやっている行動も不善たる行動で
無智の心ですか それは二つ三種類ありますと
で それはまあ不善たる行動だと
ですから 貪瞋痴に基づいてする行動はほとんど不善になるんです
で そこら辺でももうちょっと詳しく考えちゃうと
我々の生き方っていうのは大体ほとんど貪瞋痴に基づいてやってるんです
で 生まれてからもうやっぱりまあほとんどの心はむさぼりですか
欲ですか で 欲の心で行動している
で その間ではいろんな怒りが出てきたりして
怒りでも行動している
で それからあまりわからないんだから
物事はわからないんだから
混乱状態にいて またいろんな行動をすると
人間の行動っていうのは
まあほとんどまあ九十九パーセントぐらいはまあ貪瞋痴なんですね
ですから そういう立場で見ると
仏教の立場で見ると 人間の行動はほとんど不善であって
まああんまりいいことをするっていうことは言えないんですよ
で そこら辺で智慧がある人々には
いくらか何か自分を守ることができるんですね
例えば勉強するということはありますね
子供には とにかく欲を目的にして勉強させたりする
でも欲のためにとか とにかく言うのは
道徳というのは欲ばっかしなんですね
ですから そういう偉くなるために
あるいはいい仕事を見つかるために
楽に生きてるためにも
なんとか何とかということで
欲のために勉強するならば
それはもう不善たる不善たる行動になってしまうと
そこを知恵ある人には
まあ人間で生まれたからには勉強しなくちゃいけない
知識なければいけませんと
で 知識あった方が自分の役にも立って人の役にも立ちますよと
自分の仕事を食べる分ぐらいは自分で仕事をしなくちゃいけない
それぐらい能力を身につけなくちゃいけないと
それはしょうがないと
やむを得ないものだと理解してやると
そこにはまああんまりむさぼりは働いてないんですね
まあやむを得ないことだから
で それだけで行動すると
結構普通の生き方も善たる行為に変えてしまっちゃうんですね
で 怒りがありまして まあやっぱり気に入らないものに対しては怒ったり
競争したり 戦ったり あるいはもう元気がないと勉強するためにライバルを作っちゃって
あいつには負けてたまれませんとかなんとか思って勉強したりするし
で それを大人になっても同じ癖をついていて
もう怒りで怒りでも頑張っちゃうし
もったいないんですね
やっぱり人生は全部罪なんですね
もうただ単に何の罪もない勉強なんですけど
このライバル意識でやっちゃうと怒りですから
ありとあらゆる罪を重ねちゃうんですね
だからそれは嘘じゃないんです
なぜならば そういうふうに勉強すると
かなり自分が疲れる ストレス溜まる
もうやりきれなくなる
自殺したくなる 結局は
それは自分の行為の結果であって
悪いことをずっとしてきたんだから
まあそういう風になってしまっちゃうんですね
会社にしたっても ライバル的に他のもの
会社やら他の人やらみんな倒してやるという気持ちでやっちゃうと
それは全く不善たる行為であって
不善たる行為には現世においてもそういう酷い結果が出てくるんですね
健康は失うは 精神落ち着きがなくなるは
会社は無茶苦茶になるは
家庭は無茶苦茶になるは
やがて自分も病気になって
突然何か病気になって倒れる
あるいはもう自殺してしまうかとか
どっちかいろんなことになってしまうんですね
ですから 自分の怒りに基づいて
そういうふうにやっていることによって
不善という罪が罪重なって言っちゃうんですね
そこで智慧ある人は やっぱりそれはもうやめた方がいいんです
競争するんじゃなくて
自分が自分の能力に ある能力を生かしてるんだと
そこで自分より能力ある人はもっと先に行ったっても
それは構いませんし 能力ない人は後からうろうろもう来たっても
それはしょうがないし
例えば試験なんかにはあるならば
それはもう 300人試験受験するんだと
一人二人しか会社に選べないんだと
その場合はみんなもうライバルだ
敵だと思ってやっちゃうと罪であって
そうじゃなくて みんなで受験しましょうと
能力ある人は選べればいいんじゃないかと
そこでもう 300人のみんなもう 298
人も失格になって自分が選ばれたと
それは別に自分には能力あったんだから選ばれたんだと
能力のない人々にとっては
それはしょうがないんですからね
ですから そういうふうにちょっとだけ心変えれば
智慧をもって行動するならば
我々の普通の日常生活も不善から善に変えちゃうんですね
で なかなか普通の人間にはそういう知識がないんだから
不善ばっかりやってるんです
人間であるから結婚しなくちゃいけないんだけど
結婚自体は不善な行為であって
人間であるから子供作ったり家庭作ったりしなくちゃいけないんだけど
それまた不善な行為になったりして
仕事をしなくちゃいけないんだけど
それはまた不善な行為になったりして
人の結婚式やお葬式やら
そういうことに参加しなくちゃいけないんだけど
そこにまた自分を見栄を張ったり威張ったり
ああだこうだということがいっぱい出てくるんだから
あるいは嫌で もう行きたくはないんだけど
行かなかったら色々批判されるんだからとかね
そういうことで行かれていったりとか
どうせやらなくちゃいけないことなんですけど
そこにいっぱい罪をして
罪を罪重ねて罪重ねて
人間っていうのは結局不幸で死んでしまっちゃうんですね
だから我々はいつのいつの時代で社会を見ても
混乱だらけで 競争だらけで
戦いだらけで 戦争だらけで
お互いになかなかうまくいかないで苦しみだけになってるんですね
そこで釈尊のメッセージは別にもう仕事を辞めなさい
結婚するのをやめなさいとか
そんなことは言ってないんです
あなた方の人生はそのままで結構ですよと
ただ心の気持ちだけですか
心の目的ですか それだけちょっと入れ替えなさいと
ということなんですね
ある日 お釈迦様はこう言ってるんですね
ある家庭の奥様かな 普通の奥様で
大変清らかな心で 慈しみの心で
旦那の面倒を見て 子供の面倒を見て
家を守って ごく普通の生活をすると天国に生まれ変わりますよと
善行為をしなかったら
徳を積まなかったら あなたは天国に行けませんという宗教は信じなきゃ天国には行くくはないという
そういうへんてこりんな非合理的な話言ってないんです
同じことを王様にも言ってるんです
王が欲を置いといて 人に慈しみの心で自分の国民が我が子のように愛して
法に従ってちゃんと道徳を守って国を守ると
それは善たる行為ですよと
その代わりに自分が偉いんだと
力強い王だと だからもう私は怖いものは何もないんだと言って
いじめたい放題人をいじめて
税金取りたい放題税金取ったりして
で遊びたい放題遊んでやっちゃったら
もうどんとすごい地獄に落ちますよと
というふうにおっしゃってますから
人間には特別に社会から逃げろとかね
森の中に隠れようと そんなことは言ってないんです
ただ 人間は無知だから
普通の自分の毎日24時間やってることは
まあかわいそうに罪にしていて
それによって苦しみの結果を得ている
もうほんのちょっと智慧が働かせちゃうと
ごく普通の人生何も変わってないんだけど
そこに美しい明るい生き方が現れてくるんです
全然ストレスも溜まらないし
人と喧嘩することもないし
仕事はまたかえってうまくいっちゃうし
悩む苦しみはほとんど消えていっちゃうんですね
楽しく楽に生きていられる
そのために ややこしいいろんなことを工夫したり
勉強したり いろいろ修行を試してみたりとか
もうほとんど要りません
普通の人生の幸福のためには
ほんのちょっと頭の入れ替えだけなんですね
必要なのは ですから そういう点から見ると
仏教というのはいかに知識的で合理的な教えかということが我々には理解できると思います
仏教というのはほとんど心理学ですから
で 仏教の道徳っていうのはやっぱり普遍的なもので
時間感 時間の流れには流れていかないんです
仏教でやっと罪だと言っている行為っていうのは10種類しかないんです
よくまとめて それは悪10善と分けているんですね
この10悪っていうのは
殺生するなとか 人のものを盗るなと
欲情ない行為をするなという体の行為3つと
嘘を言うなと 噂を言うなと
無駄話するなと 悪口を言うなという言葉の行為を4つと
それから余計な怒りといわゆる精神的な病気みたいな
心の中でも何のわけもなく怒りが生まれてくるんですね
そういう何の関係もない心に生まれてくる余計な怒りと余計な欲
いわゆる頭の中でいろんなことを妄想したり
ああなりたい こうなりたい
あれ欲しい これ欲しい
あれやればいい これやればいいとかね
もう限りない欲は頭だけ回転する場合があるんですね
それは人間にはだいたい
ああいうことあればいいんじゃない
これぐらいお金あればいいんじゃないかとかね
これできればいいんだとかね
で こうなればいいんじゃないかとかね
そういうのは頭の中でよく回転しちゃうんですね
例えば分かりやすく言うといえば
例えば健康にある考え方もちょっと余計なんですね
ものすごい元気で力強くて健康でずっと生きていたいんだと
長生きしたいんだとかね
で そこをあんまりちょっと考えすぎになっちゃうと
かなり苦しみがそこに生まれてくるんです
長生きしよう もうすごい健康的で元気でようではないかと
そこはちょっと非合理的で
頭だけの欲だけなんですね
このそういう余計な欲も余計な怒りも邪見も捨てなさいと
それは罪ですよ そういうふうに頭だけの罪が3つ
言葉の罪は4つ 体の罪は3つと10種類を教えているんです
それだけなんですね いわゆる項目として仏教で出てくる罪というのは
それ見たっても他の宗教の罪のリストと比べると
もういかに仏教はしっかりしているかということがそこにわかると思います
ちゃんと身口意に分けられて
じゃあキリスト教の十戒はそういうふうに分けられますかと
大雑把なんですね 殺すなかれと
汝は殺すなかれ それで解釈するときは人を殺すなかれと
どうやって thou shalt not kill という言葉が人を殺すなとなったんですかね
動物は殺してもいいやと
だから曖昧なんですね
結局 戒律は殺すなかれとありますから
まあそこは僕らに 僕ら仏教の立場から見ればしっかりしてるんです
その項目だけはね 殺すなと
でも解釈では他のところで神様が人々のために動物を創造しました
あだこだという またもう何も根拠のないへんてこりんな話入っちゃいますから
その話は話は道徳の中に紛れ込んじゃって
じゃあまあ人を殺すなだけに人だけになっちゃう
それまた解釈はまた進んでいって
人と言ったっても どうせ神様を信じている人だけ天国に行くんだから
他の人はどうせ地獄に行くんだから
まあもうちょっと人の命の価値が薄くなって薄くなっちゃうんですね
どうせ邪教だから 野蛮人だから
どうせ生きてたっても死んじゃったら
まあそれで地獄ですからと
神に逆らってる人だからと
ということで 偉大なる神様に逆らってるんだから
別に生きる権利がなくなっちゃうんだと思って
平気で人まで殺してしまっちゃう
ですから 大体この絶対的な神を信じている宗教はもうみんな戦争するんですね
でもその宗教の教えではそんなことやるなとしっかりと言ってるんです
イスラム教でもキリスト教でも
それで他の十戒にした十戒の他の項目にしたっても
全部覚えてませんだけど
まあそんなにしっかりした普遍的なものっていうのはもうないんですね
怒りに対して何か項目はありますけどね
まああんまりそんなにもね
しっかりしてないんですね
仏教になると やっぱりそれをちゃんと身口意に分けて
体の行為3つと 言葉の行為4つと
心だけの頭だけの行為は3つと
その10種類10だけは10だけはまあ不善でありますと
罪ですよと言ってるんですね
それからそれで終わるわけじゃないんです
で 貪瞋痴に基づいた心で行動する場合は
全部不善の中に入りますと
その場合は行動は貪瞋痴でするか
不貪不瞋痴でするかというのは人の自由なんですね
例えば学校で子供たちに教える
それは貪瞋痴で教えることもできるし
不貪不瞋痴で教えることもできるんですね
ですから 教えることについては
善悪判断は心の持ち方によって決めなくちゃいけない
先生が有名になりたく
威張りたく 自分の教室の生徒たちはみんなもう高い点数で合格しましたよとか
そういうふうな まあなんとか気持ちでとかね
あるいは給料もらうんだからという給料だけを目的にしたりとかやっちゃうと
やっぱり貪瞋痴に入っちゃいますから
不善であって やっぱりこの子供たちに
自分の生徒たちにちゃんと教えて
もうちゃんと自分を知ってるものを与えてあげて
まあみんなも育ててあげたいんだと
私は育ててもらったんだから
その分はこの生徒たちにも育て上げますよと
という愛情というですか
慈しみの心ですか それでやっちゃうと
その教えることは善なる行為になっちゃうんですね
ですから そういう風に
この自分の心次第で罪になるか善になるかという行為もいっぱい世の中にあります
どんな行動でも分けられますよ
善か不善かに そこで危ないのは
そういう仏教の知識がない人々は
やってることはほとんど不善になってしまっちゃって
で 仏教的なこの心理学的的な立場から物事を知っている人は気を付けるんですね
微かな行動であろうが
やっぱり貪瞋痴ではダメですよと
子供自分も子供を叱る時でも
やっぱり怒りで叱ってはいけないんだ
それはやっぱり子供の未来を考えて
成長を考えて 愛情で 優しい心でということが入ってきて
それから叱っちゃうと
そういう気を付けると
常に 嫌で嫌で料理作っちゃったら
もう料理作るのはもう大変作られるし
その上罪も 背負うし そうじゃなくて
もう振ったり蹴ったり状態でしょう
そうじゃなくて やっぱり自分がこの場合は自分が料理作らなくちゃいけないんだ
だからみんな美味しいご飯食べて
まあ楽しくなって 楽しく勉強したり仕事をしたりしてくださいという
みんな食べてちょうだいという気持ちで料理作っちゃうと
もうだいたいまあ善行為になっちゃうんですね
結構世の中にある現象なんですけど
まあ母の料理って料理っていうのはみんなありがたがりますけど
それよりたまにおばあちゃんの料理は大変気に入る時あるんですね
で あまり料理作りません
たまに何か作ってくると
なんとなくあっちはおばあちゃんだから年上だから
孫たちやら自分の子供たちやら
なんかすごく愛情みたいなもの
それだけがあって 作ってくれると
そこをなんかな すごくこの雰囲気がね
美しくなっちゃうんですね
そこら辺はやっぱり愛情で優しい気持ちでやりますから
まあみんな心で喜びを感じちゃう
優しさを感じちゃう それで生きていることはそこで幸福が生まれてくるんですね
ですから このたとえ料理を作ることにしたっても
他のことにしたっても
それは不正になるようにもできるし
善になるようにもすることはできるんですね
ですから あくまでも自分次第なんですね
生き方は 神様次第ではないんです
教えてくれる仏教 宗教を教えてくれる先生次第でもないんですね
ですから 仏教はいつでも人間の主は自分でやると
自分が地獄に行くか天国に行くか
これは自分が決めるものであって
自分に決められるならば
天国か地獄か自分は神様と同じだからね
ですから仏教で神様はもう出てこないんですね
場面には 役割はないんです
この人生ドラマに ドラマでは
で 自分なんですね 自分が不幸というならば
人に文句言ったっても
それは単なる怒りであって
自分がただ気が付いてなくて
自分がずっと悪いことをやってきたことなんですね
そこでなんで我々はそういう自分が悪いことをやってきたかとわからないんですかね
私は一生懸命やったのにと文句言うでしょ？なんでそれなのにそんな結果ですかと
そういう文句を言う場合は
これはむさぼりと怒りだけではなくて
極力無知も働いてるんですね
物事について判断がないという
そういうことで この全ての不善行為は貪瞋痴に基付いているということになっていて
それからこのそういう心は12種類しかない
で そこで私は問題に考えるのは
例えばあの怒りのことなんですけど
怒ってちょっと怒っても気持ち悪くなる
怒って人を人にもうちょっと睨んでみるとか睨むとか
それから怒って人に何か言葉話すとか
また怒ってその人を脅すとかね
また怒ってその人をぶん殴ると
または怒ってその人を怪我するとかね
あるいは怒ってその人を殺してしまうとかね
その場合はいろんなランクがあるんですね
怒りの 人を殺すことと
ただ怒って気持ち悪くなるということは随分違いますから
でもアビダンマではそういう心は2つしかないんですね
怒った場合は ドーマナッサハカタン
パティサンペヨッタン
アサンカーリキチッタン
ササンカーリキチッタン
そこでアサンカーリキ
ササンカーリキっていうのは
あの 業無業という差だからさ
あんまり差がないんですね
鈍いかもう鋭いかっていうぐらいのことだから
ですから怒りの心一つしかないんですよ
もうもっと私人で考えちゃうと
たった一つの心でいろんな行動できますかとね
そこら辺ちょっと問題なんですけど
やっぱりこのその問題はこの心の強弱で解決するんですね
いわゆる心処で 心の中にいろんなこの怒りという心処が入って
その怒りが 心処がすごい強烈だったら
人を殺すこともできるし
心処の怒りがもう軽いんだったら
まあまあ ただ悪口言ってそれで止まったりとかね
そういう風になっていて
ですから そういうふうなことで
この心の数をできるだけ少なくしているんです
行為によって心が違いますけど
それを全部心として扱っちゃうと
もう奥たんえで済みませんからね
そういうことも考えておいてください
じゃあ今日は 善行為の心を説明いたします
順番ではないかもしれませんだけど
何ページでしたっけ？ 29ページですね
29ページ このアビダンマの分析もそれなりのあり方ありますけど
わかりやすくするために
今日はここから始まります
いいことをすると 人には 24種類の心が生まれるんです
いわゆる 24種類の心に基づいていいことをしているんです
その不善は 12と その倍なんですね
善の場合は ですから 結構希望はあるんです
心の数から見ようと いいことをするためには
希望はあるんだけど この 24の中で
8種類だけなんです 我々一般の人に生まれるのは
残りはちょっと違うんです
それは瞑想して修行の世界で生まれる心なんですね
普通我々行動するといいことをすると生まれる心は 8種類しかない
悪いことをすると生まれる心は 12種類あるんです
そこら辺ちょっと問題で
やっぱり一般の人間にとっては不善の方が多いということなんです
修行したり瞑想したりすると
この残りのレベル高いの善たる心も生まれていきます
そこで心が善か不善か決めるためには
必要な決まりは貪瞋痴か不貪不瞋不痴かというどっちかなんですね
で 今日の心は 何でしたっけ？不貪不瞋不痴
むさぼりがない 怒りがない
智慧がある その心素が入っている行動は心が善たる行動ですと
で 善不善は混ぜれません
例えば欲がないんだけど
怒りと怒りがあるならば
もう完全にもう不善であって
善たる行為にはもう善不善不貪不瞋痴は言えませんだけど
やっぱりあの三つは全く入ってないんですね
貪瞋痴は全く入ってない
ですから善たる心が生まれると
すごく心は軽くて 気持ちは良くて明るいんです
不善なことを生まれると心は暗いんです
例えば欲が生まれてもどこかで暗いんですね
いろんな欲でいろんなことを楽しがったり
遊んだり ニコニコ笑ったりするんだけど
やっぱり笑わずにいられない
楽しめないでいられない
遊ばないでいられないぐらい落ち着きがないんですね
そういう人々は ですから
結局は暗いといえば暗いんです
あまり遊びにふけたり
いろんな楽しみばっかし追っかけていったりして
何か一つのゲームをやって
それ終わっちゃうと また新しい何かしらものが出て
またそれを買って またそれをまたそういうふうにいろんなもの必死になって
もう死ぬ思いでみんな遊んでるんですね
だから明るい明るいと
明るくはないんです あんまりにも暗いんです
だから何かふけること
何かなかったらもうどうしようもない状態なんですね
だから現代若者なんか見ると
ものすごい不精神的な不安定で
何かもうやってないと
もうどうするかわからないんですね
ですから もうたまにあるんですよ
でしょ？もう本当に何のことない
ない 普通の小学生 中学生たちがどこかいたところで人を蹴っ飛ばしたり
ぶっ殺したりしたという
公園で遊んでたところで
ちょっとしたホームレスの人を見て
その人をぶん殴って 殴ったところで攻撃はしない
それでさらに欲しくなって殴っちゃったら
その人を殺しちゃう で
未成年だからものすごくうまく自分たちももう逃げちゃうと
法律から で そういうことはあり得るんですね
もしその子供たちに他のなんか夢中になる遊びがあったならば
それをやっちゃうんです
人殺しはしない ということは
結局心が暗いということなんですね
落ち着きがなかったということなんですね
たまたまもう夢中になる何かなかった
それで出会った浮浪者を殺したとかね
そういうケースいくつかありましたからね
ですから もうこの遊ぶ心というのはね
仏教では欲の心と言うし
それは暗い 善たる行為はいつでも明るい
心はどういうふうに分析するかというと
まずこのソウマナッササハガ
ソウマナッササハガと心とウペッカーサハガと心とまた 2つに分けて考える
これはいいことをする時
どんな心が生まれるか
大体いいことをすると
すごい喜 楽しみ 心が明るく
すごく楽しみを感じて
その行動をする 別に特別な楽しみを感じてない
苦しみを感じてるわけじゃなくて
あの 何と言いますか 心は冷静というか
この これはキグーと日本訳なんですね
こっちはシャグーとなってますからね
それはまあこちらの感じでそうなってますけど
ウペッカーっていうのはニュートラルフィーリングなんですね
ソウマナッササハガっていうのはもっと喜びの感情なんですね
楽しみ なんか明るい 楽しい
人間っていうのはすごい元気で明るくでないといいことはしないね
ごく一般的に見てもね
よく心の余裕があって
楽しみがあるといいことをする
心の余裕がない場合はもう腹が立って
もう全然いいことはしない
いわゆる機嫌が 例えば何か活動に運動に参加してくださいと頼む時でも
その人の機嫌がいい時頼んだらいいよ
やってあげますよとすぐ言ってくれる
機嫌が悪いと言っちゃったら追い出される
ですから やっぱりいいことをするということは
やっぱりすごく機嫌が良くて
本人が喜んでいる時はやりやすいんですね
そういうことで だいたいいいことをしましょうと
なぜならば それは当然明るい楽しい行動なんですね
たまに別にワクワクすると楽しみがないんだけど
一応心は落ち着いて余裕があって
じゃあいいですよ やりましょうというシャグー
ウペッカー ニュートラルフィーリングでもするか
あるいは大変楽しいフィーリングで感情でするか
どっちかに分けられる
次に心の分析になってくるのはニャーナサンパユッタ
ニャーナビッパヤッタ
[背景音]ニャーナというのは一応智慧ですね
智慧というか まあ知というまあ智慧という意味なんですけど
智慧がちゃんとありますか？智慧がないかという 2つ
ここで智慧っていうのは
やっぱり物事をちゃんと理解しているという意味で
例えばいいことはするべきですよと
いいことをするのは当たり前ですよというふうな理解があって
大体世の中の人を見ると
なかなかこれないんですね
嫌でいいことをするんですね
もうやむをえず自分のことをするのは一番正しいんだと
儲かることは正しいんであって
人を助けるのはもうまあもうどうでもいいと
それでもどうしても逃げられない場合は
まあなんとかすると いろんな国々から批判されると
じゃあ援助してあげますという風にも
そういうこともなかなか
政府にしたってもよく見られることで
それでそれはもうニャーナがないんですね
みんなに嫌がまあいいや
もうしょうがない 嫌われると批判されてるんだと思って援助しちゃう
それで 1回 2回援助しちゃったら
それは大変受けると受けると
あ 我々はこれでもうすごい金持ちな国じゃ
強い国じゃと思って もうそれからもう頼まなくたってもどんどん援助してしまっちゃうと
どっちでもニャーナがないんですね
まあ国際的に見ると なかなか日本はいろんな国際的な援助したり活動したりするんだけど
評価されないんですね
外国からは 他の国ではそんな大したことになってやってないんだけど
結構結構評価されちゃうし
それはもしかするとそこら辺にもうニャーナがない
智慧がないかなと 僕はよく考えたら
このものすごい膨大な額ね
イラクとクウェートのね
戦争の場合はね 出したんだけど
もうそういう戦争に参加したこの国からかなり批判されちゃったんですね
アメリカが貢献した分よりはもっと分よりというか
もっとほとんど同じぐらい日本も貢献したんですね
でも偉くなったのはアメリカで大変批判されたのは日本で
でも私の個人的な立場では
僕はお金出したこと自体ものすごい反対でしたけどね
一人当たり 1万円ぐらいでしょうね
あのお金は 国民の冗談じゃないんだけど
全然あげませんと堂々と言った方がもっといいのにね
まああげないんだったら
でもいいでしょ しっかりすればね
で 言われるんだから それでやっぱりお金ある国という風に言われるんだから
誰よりも高いお金出そうとかね
そこでやっぱり見栄やらね
まあ罪ばっかしなんですね
国民のお金ね 大事なお金を使って罪を稼ぐと
そういうのは智慧がやっぱり必要なんですね
国家としても国民としても個人としてもね
知恵が必要なんです そうするとみんな楽しいんです
国を褒められるとね みんな楽しいでしょうに
だから国がやることは国民がやることですから
なんかちょっとおかしいことをやっちゃうと批判されると
やっぱり誰でもやっぱり気持ちが良くないんですね
これは当たり前であって
そういうことで 私たちにしても
個人個人にしても そういう知恵がなくやる行動も結構あるんです
この場合はもうニャーナっていうのはやっぱりいいことをするべきですよと
人を助けるべきですよという
当たり前でしょうと そんなことはというふうな理解あるならば知恵がある
あるいは仏教的なこの心の働きをよく知って
仏教の心理学をよく理解して
カルマの法則を理解していると
それも知恵があるというカテゴリーに入っちゃうんです
どうしようもない 逃げられない
あげるしか方法ないやという気持ちで出しちゃうと
そんな知恵が働いてない
例えばインドなんかにこの参拝ですか
もうそういう行ったら
もう必ずこの専門の乞食たちが来るんですね
あの 彼らの仕事で結構金落ちなんですもう
ただで金もらって ですからプロだから物を買うということはもう大変プロで
いろんな演技をして もうお金ちょうだいとかね
で もうサーッと入っちゃうんです
すごい数で でもある面で怖くなる
自分持ってるものを奪って帰っていったらどうしようかと
あんまり奪うことはしませんだけどね
まあ向こうは仕事だからね
で 怖くもなる で ものすごいしつこいんですね
もうないと言ったっても
もうとにかく追ってくる
それまたちゃんと自分がレストランでご飯食べてお金払う時とか
何か買い物する時とか
何かそういうところに何かお布施している時とか
その時サッと前に来て手を出したりするんですね
そこでお金ないんだからあっち行けという風に言えなくなっちゃう
もう現行犯で捕まえるんです
で あげなかったらずっと後ろから追ってくる
車に乗っても車の窓からまだ手を出して車石渡したら走っても来るんですね
それでもあげるしか方法ないんですね
そういう風にもありとあらゆる角度から攻めてもう金取ると
そういうのはあるんです
ですから その場合もやっぱり
別にニャーナですかね
知恵で そんなこと考えて
やっぱり貧しい人々は助けなくちゃいけないんですからとかね
我々にはお金あって この人々のお金がないんではないかと
だからほんの一部ぐらい分けなくても何のことないんではないかとか何とかそんな考える余裕はあるわけじゃないんです
でもその場合も知恵ある人だったら
すぐもう もうすぐあげるかあげませんと
自分がそんなのあげなくてもいいと決めちゃったらあげませんとかね
決めますけどね でもそんなうまくは人間いきませんだからね
どうしてもあげるんじゃなくて
向こうに取られるということになっちゃう
とにかくそれも悪い行為じゃないんだからね
やっぱり人に見返りを求めないであげたものだからね
乞食にあげたもので それでまた見返りは全然考えてないんだから
それはもう善行為なんですけど
やっぱりニャーナが入ってない
それで心が4種類になっちゃうんですね
いわゆるソウマナサハガタのニャーナサンパユッタと
それでニャーナヴィッパユッタ一つと
ウペッカーサハガタの心はまたこれの一つとこれの一つになって 4
つになるんですね それはソウマナッサハガタニャーナサンパユッタ心
ソウマナッサハガタニャーナヴィッパユッタ心
ウペッカーサハガタニャーナサンパユッタ心
ウペッカーサハガタニャーナヴィッパユッタ心と4種類の心が出てくるんです
この 4つをまた 2つに分けちゃうんですね
アサンカーリカ ササンカーリカ
有業 無業 業があるかないかと
アサンカーリカっていうのは業はない
無業 ササンカーリカっていうのは業が入っていると
有業ですね で またそこには業っていうのは心の中のもうもう働きであって
心の中 いわゆるすぐ鋭くさっさと判断して行動する人々がアサンカーリカ
無業 心の中ではどうしようか
どうしようかだとか もう時間かからないんですね
行動には時間がかからない
瞬時に判断して行動する
いわゆる鈍いか鋭いかというぐらいの性格的な差なんですね
それは 大体性格的な鈍い人はほとんど鈍い
行動は鈍い 理解は鈍い
遅くちょっと遅くなる
鋭い人はもう勉強することにしても
すぐ聞いてすぐ分かったと
行動にしてもすぐ行動してしまうと
行動は早い それはみんなこの無業ということで
で 結構